[Music]
oh the time has come for final exam
weary pit members of the press against
one another to separate those who've
been paying very close attention to the
news from those who haven't
this week's defending champion is once
again Katie Pavlich of Town Hall or
challenger this week is Fox News
correspondent our friend Kevin cork and
they're both ready to go are you right
now Kevin you're facing off against
someone who has not been defeated who is
remarkably cool under the pressure are
you ready I'm ready let's do this
harshest competition yet the fiercest
competition yet good luck all right well
you know the rules kitty obviously
you've used them to your advantage
Kevin if you don't here's what they are
hands on buzzers I ask the question the
first one to buzz in gets to answer you
have to wait until they finish asking
the question in order to do that you can
answer what say acknowledge by saying
your name each correct answer is worth
one point if you get it wrong you lose a
point like the SAT best of five wins are
you ready let's do any outstanding
question one President Trump says he's
now looking beyond the Marine Corps and
the Air Force to create a whole new
branch of the military with a focus
beyond this earth what will the name of
this group be that's the space you have
of course ladies and gentlemen reflexes
you see you're very confident is it
space force so we're going to create a
space force Navy Air Force Marines Coast
Guard
air force right air force and what are
we going to do space force space force I
love that question too
a New Jersey man was seen getting to
work in New York City in an unusual way
he crossed the Hudson River to Manhattan
not by car not by boat not by train but
by which mode of transportation by
paddleboard Katie paddleboard is it a
paddleboard that seems unlikely
are you right a Jersey City man he was
paddleboarding across the Hudson River
to get to his job in Manhattan Scott
Holt wearing a suit as he made the trek
across the water
he says his trip took him about half an
hour and he made it in time meaning he
made his meeting
straight okay it's 1-1 going into
question three an animal in Australia
interrupted a women's soccer game when
that animal dashed across the field and
started kicking the ball what kind of
animal was it a kangaroo
Katie kangaroo was it it came well it's
Australia okay I wasn't racing across
the field of play scattering guys left
and right women's soccer match yesterday
delay the game almost 32 minutes it did
at the same time get to show off it's
goalie skills as players eventually
Kings attention try to drive it right
come on it has to be a train member it
was in deep yeah it was either a
kangaroo or koala and you guessed
correctly all right so it's two to one
going into question for evening
commuters in the state of Florida got a
shock but being Florida they were not
that shocked they noticed something
clinging to the hood of a car traveling
down the highway at 70 miles per hour
the car was swerving from side to side
what was it clinging to the hood
Kevin cork it was a guy who was clinging
to the hood of the car driven by his
ex-girlfriend if I'm not mistaken the
Florida man that's Florida Florida man
you've got over the tail and that wasn't
a guy clinging to the hood of the car
it was the viral video so wild it almost
seems hard to believe a man clinging
down a Florida Highway 70 miles per hour
holding on for dear life for nearly 15
minutes
all right to to to going in to question
five where it's always right here for
some reason the finest direction here it
is there is a viral video on the
internet that shows man's best friend
doing something extraordinary to a
police officer what was it oh you got it
CPR CPR Mon CPR his name was poncho I
don't believe you let's rotate please
poncho is a police dog they could eat
his face judges are saying they
considered that question impossible that
no normal person could answer it they
were trying to stump you Katie they
failed congratulations Kevin Corky makes
you feel better there's no way I
couldn't got your face again and then
she go Katie you're getting the mug
there you go that's our Eric well mug
commemorating his we have mental
appearance on our show great to see you
both thank you well soon